thanks to surf shark for helping support
this episode
hey crazies you know how we always see
the same side of the moon the side with
the face on it
well that can happen with planets too
if there's enough time
the same side of a planet could always
be facing the star it's orbiting
continuous sunlight on one side and
continuous darkness on the other
it would make the planet kind of look
like an eyeball but will that ever
happen to earth
[Music]
if you give a system enough time it'll
settle into the most stable
configuration it can find
you could randomize the motion of
particles in a room all you want but
after bumping into each other a bunch of
times they'll settle into something
fairly predictable it's a stable
configuration any minor deviation and
the forces will bring them back
in astronomy configurations like this
are governed by gravity and they're
called resonances
we usually label them with some kind of
ratio for example three of jupiter's
moons have a one two four orbital
resonance
that means in the time it takes one moon
to go around once the others go around
two and four times respectively but
today's video isn't about orbital
resonance it's about spin orbit
resonance
rather than multiple objects having a
ratio between them there's a ratio
between the spin and the orbit of a
single object
kind of like how the planet mercury has
a 3 2 spin orbit resonance with the sun
that means for every three rotations or
spins there are two full orbits
for some places on mercury that means
you could have two sunrises or sunsets
in a single day which is kind of weird
our own moon has a special kind of
spin-orbit resonance called synchronous
rotation
that means the ratio between the spin
and the orbit is one to one
the time it takes to spin around once
equals the time it takes to orbit once
so the same side of the moon always
faces the earth
if you took a picture of the moon every
day for a month the resulting gif would
look like this
and yes i pronounced it gif it's
graphics interchange format
graphics
gif
anyway synchronous rotation is actually
a very common phenomenon even in our own
solar system
both of mars moons do it all four of
jupiter's big moons do it some of
saturn's moons even do it
it happens a lot is what i'm saying
all it takes is time but how much time
depends on the circumstances
in fact if the two objects were
perfectly spherical none of this would
ever happen it's the imperfections that
make spin orbit resonance possible which
if you ask me is the most interesting
part of this whole process it's the
imperfections that make it beautiful
contrary to what we tend to think no
object is ever perfectly rigid
i've mentioned in a previous video that
earth has an equatorial bulge because it
spins
well the moon spins too which means it
also bulges at the equator
those graphics are extremely exaggerated
though
the earth's oblateness is only about
point three percent the moons is about
point one percent we're exaggerating for
clarity now spin is not the only thing
that can cause ball
there are other things that can cause
bulging
it had to be said
nobody had to say it let's try to get
this line again now spin is not the only
thing that can cause bulging gravity can
do it too
the earth and moon are pretty far apart
but they still pull on each other that
gravitational tug can and will cause
bulging along the line between them
that's not necessarily along the equator
of either object so we can't call it an
equatorial bulge we call it a tidal
bulge
tidal as in the tides this effect is
most noticeable with the oceans
the earth's gravity may hold the ocean
down but the moon's gravity pulls a
little to the side
that combined with a massive amount of
fluid pressure causes a bulge in the
ocean
this doesn't just happen with liquids
though the earth may be solid rock but
it can be deformed in exactly the same
way
remember nothing is perfectly rigid
not only does the ocean bulge but all
the rock underneath it does too just not
as much
how does this cause that sync lotron
radiation though it's synchronous
rotation also known as tidal locking and
hi where have you been do you really
want to know the answer to that actually
no never mind
anyway synchronous rotation occurs
because of torque
you know how forces can cause a change
in speed well torque is like a
rotational force it can cause a change
in rotational speed
for any spin-orbit resonance to occur
there must be torque
in our case that comes from the fact
that tidal bulges can't change instantly
if the moon is rotating quickly its
bulge is going to lag behind of the
planet moon line that means the forces
on either side don't line up you get a
torque opposite the rotation which slows
it down a bit
it's not a lot those bulges in the
animation are exaggerated but if it
happens over and over again for a
hundred million year million million
years worth of millionaires yeah
the millionaires
but if it happens over and over again
for a hundred million years those little
slowdowns are gonna add up
one snowflake may be pretty
insignificant but a bunch of them is an
avalanche
planetary systems tend to be around for
billions of years that's billions with a
b
the rotation of our own moon had enough
time to slow down until the bulge was
always along the planet moon line that's
when its spin equals its orbit a similar
thing would happen if the moon started
out slower instead
if it's rotating slowly its bulge is
going to get ahead of the planet moon
line that means the forces on either
side still don't line up but this time
you get a torque along the rotation
which speeds it up a bit
the end result is the same though
synchronous rotation
how long did it take to totally lock
like that
getting a number is actually kind of
tricky
we do have an equation for it as long as
we make a crap ton of approximations
there are actually so many
approximations that i don't feel
entirely comfortable using it but it's
the best we've got the general problem
is so complex that it's completely
unsolvable
what this equation can do though is give
us an idea of what factors are involved
and how important each one is
we've got some things you'd probably
expect the rotation speed of the moon
the radius of the moon the orbital
radius of the moon the mass of the
planet and the gravitational constant of
the universe
all things we either know or can find by
taking a few measurements unfortunately
these two we often don't know very well
something called the tidal love number
which measures the elasticity of the
moon and the specific dissipation
function which tells us how much energy
is lost to heat
we do know them for our moon which is
how i knew it took 100 million years
if you're trying to calculate this for
any other object just just give up now
we can see some patterns in this
equation though
if the elasticity is 0 meaning the moon
is perfectly rigid then time is infinite
tidal locking never happens because no
elasticity means no bulges
the more energy that gets dissipated the
longer it's going to take
we can also see the radius and the
orbital radius are to the 5th and 6th
powers respectively that makes the time
particularly sensitive to those values a
moon orbiting much closer to its planet
is going to tidal lock a lot sooner what
about the planet's bulge oh that's a
great question
earth rotates about 27 times faster than
the moon orbits so its own tidal bulge
gets ahead of the planet moon line and
the tidal forces slow the rotation
given enough time the earth could slow
down enough that it would tidally lock
to the moon
the same side of the earth would always
face the moon
how long would that take
don't get your hopes up
a generous lower bound says it'll take
at least 50 billion years
considering the sun will go red giant in
four to five billion there isn't nearly
enough time
but this has happened elsewhere in our
solar system
pluto and its moon karen do this
they're much closer to each other in
distance size and mass than the earth
moon system so it took a lot less time
tidal locking with the sun will take
even longer
this scenario doesn't stand a chance of
happening
but we have seen it happen outside our
own solar system
in the trappist-1 system several of its
planets are tidally locked to the star
it's a small red dwarf so the planets
are a lot closer to each other and to
the star
plus red dwarfs last for like a trillion
years
that's the kind of system where we'd
expect to see an eyeball planet like
this
the lit side would be a desert hellscape
the dark side a frozen wasteland
life would only be possible in the thin
boundary between the sides
it would be a land of eternal dusk with
dangers lurking in every shadow
kind of like life on the internet
today's sponsor surf shark can help with
that
surf shark is a vpn or virtual private
network which adds an extra level of
encryption to your internet experience
if you're like me you use some kind of
incognito or private mode in your
browser
but that only prevents your device from
recording what you're doing your isp
still keeps a record of your traffic and
any websites you visit can too
that data can be used to serve you
targeted ads or even determine your
political leanings
surfshark masks your ip address thereby
hiding your location and activity it'll
confuse your isp and any websites you
don't log into
for the rest just log out when you're
not using them
as for surf shark they have a no log
policy for all users best of all it
works on all your devices at the same
time if this sounds like a service you'd
like to use go to the link in the
description below and enter promo code
asylum you'll get 83 off and three extra
months for free which is a good deal
it'll also let surf shark know you heard
about them for me which helps out the
channel
so would you like to live on a tidally
locked planet please share in the
comments
thanks for liking and sharing this video
a special thanks goes out to my patreon
patrons and youtube members like online
book club and christopher sheila for
their generous support
don't forget to subscribe if you'd like
to keep up with us and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
what did i say i said don't at me but
fine i'll clarify
saying superconductors have zero
resistance is sacrificing accuracy in
favor of simplicity is there resistance
below our ability to measure yes but
that doesn't make it zero
anyway thanks for watching